Générique
...
-Dopée par la crise sanitaire,
la e-santé
est en pleine explosion.
-Le numérique a vraiment permis
de révolutionner
les approches de prévention,
notamment en permettant
d'avoir quelque chose
de plus personnalisé.
-Parfois accusé
de déshumaniser les soins,
le numérique vient plutôt
en soutien
aux professionnels
de santé.
-L'espace patient ne remplace pas
la consultation traditionnelle,
classique, cardiologique,
pas du tout.
-Au coeur de cet enjeu :
les données qu'il faut stocker,
sécuriser, mais aussi
mieux collecter.
-L'important, c'est d'avoir
suffisamment de données.
-Alors,
comment prendre le virage
du numérique pour améliorer
notre système de santé ?
La santé numérique
tiendra-t-elle ses promesses ?
C'est le thème de ce numéro.
-Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro.
On va parler du numérique,
qui est déjà omniprésent
dans le quotidien de la santé.
On ne se rend pas forcément compte,
mais le potentiel est gigantesque.
Bonjour, professeur Tesnière.
-Bonjour.
-D'abord, une définition.
La e-santé, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Est-ce que, par exemple,
quand je télécharge
sur mon téléphone une application
santé qui me permet
de mesurer mon activité physique
ou de voir quel est le rapport
entre mon poids et ma taille, etc.,
Est-ce que c'est déjà
de la santé numérique ?
-Le numérique va transformer
profondément tous les aspects
de la santé,
avec des applications,
des algorithmes,
à partir de données générées.
Ce qui est important, pour rester
dans le domaine de la santé,
c'est que ces utilisations
numériques soient validées,
que ce soit des dispositifs
médicaux ou des applications,
et c'est la différence
qu'il y a entre les outils
utilisés dans la santé
et ceux dans le bien-être.
-Vous êtes,
si je puis-dire,
le crack
de l'innovation technologique
et du numérique en santé.
Vous êtes directeur
de Paris santé campus,
anesthésiste de formation.
On va regarder tout de suite
votre portrait.
Est-ce que c'est
en tout état de cause
une révolution pour la santé,
le numérique ?
-C'est une évolution
qui va amener dans certains domaines
des révolutions
de fiabilité, de facilité
ou parfois d'analyse
que le cerveau humain
ou les capacités qu'on a aujourd'hui
ne pouvaient pas faire
et qui vont passer
dans une échelle nouvelle,
avec l'utilisation de ces outils.
-Est-ce qu'on peut dire,
professeur,
que le Covid a été
un accélérateur
de l'inclusion du numérique
dans nos vies,
et même au-delà,
dans tous les domaines
de la santé ?
-Oui, c'est tout à fait juste.
Il y avait une dynamique naissante
depuis quelques années.
La maturité des outils
était naissante,
ainsi que les usages
qu'on en faisait.
Le Covid, pour les raisons
qu'on connaît,
a été un accélérateur très fort,
à la fois avec les outils
de télémédecine,
mais aussi sur la constitution
de bases de données spécifiques,
notamment le système SI-DEP,
qui a permis d'analyser
tous les résultats de tests
de PCR en France quotidiennement
et sur l'ensemble du territoire.
Il y a d'autres exemples.
-Pour mesurer l'explosion
de la e-santé en France, regardez.
On se retrouve après.
-Le Covid a donné un grand coup
d'accélérateur à la e-santé,
et c'est bien parti pour durer,
même après les confinements.
Les Français sont restés connectés
à leurs médecins.
Le nombre de téléconsultations
est passé de 80 000 en 2019
à 9,4 millions en 2021.
La e-santé est en pleine explosion.
Son potentiel économique
est estimé
à 235 milliards d'euros
en 2023.
C'est 160 % de plus
qu'en 2019.
Mais le développement
du numérique en santé est inégal.
Il existe toujours
une fracture numérique.
17 % de la population est touchée
par l'illectronisme.
Elle n'utilise toujours pas Internet
soit parce qu'elle n'y a pas accès
soit parce qu'elle ne sait pas
utiliser les outils.
De plus, la e-santé concerne
surtout les villes
alors qu'elle pourrait être
un vecteur de lutte
contre les déserts médicaux.
7 téléconsultations
de médecine générale sur 10
sont faites par des patients
des grands pôles urbains.
Alors généraliser l'usage
de la e-santé est l'un
des grands objectifs
du Ségur du numérique en santé
et du programme
Innovation santé 2030.
Ainsi, l'Etat a investi
2 milliards d'euros
dans la santé connectée
et a lancé fin 2022
l'Agence de l'innovation en santé,
une structure qui a pour vocation
de coordonner la recherche
et l'innovation en santé,
notamment dans le numérique.
-Vous avez été anesthésiste
réanimateur.
Pour vous, qu'est-ce que ça a
changé, le numérique, dans le fond ?
-Le numérique,
ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est la possibilité
d'améliorer
ce que l'on va pouvoir faire
pour nos patients,
mieux partager les informations,
mieux expliquer
les pathologies
à des patients,
mieux suivre à distance,
mieux diagnostiquer,
notamment avec des outils
d'intelligence artificielle...
C'est la façon dont ça va permettre
d'améliorer notre système.
-Ca n'est que du progrès,
le numérique en santé ?
-Comme tous les éléments de progrès,
il y a des enjeux d'appropriation,
d'usage et de compréhension
de la valeur ajoutée
dans nos pratiques.
Et la caractéristique passionnante
de la santé,
c'est qu'on est confrontés
en permanence
à des questions éthiques.
Donc la question qui est associée
au progrès, à ces innovations,
c'est comment va-t-on faire en sorte
qu'elles n'amènent que du progrès
et qu'on permette de donner
toutes les garanties.
-Pour les patients, évidemment,
c'est un rapport transformé,
révolutionnaire,
avec la médecine et son médecin.
Je parlais de téléconsultations.
On va regarder le reportage
d'Alexia Lepéron.
Oui, il y a une autonomisation
des patients,
mais il y a certaines limites aussi
qu'on touche de très près.
-Doctolib, Qare, MédecinDirect
ou encore Lifen...
L'utilisation des applications santé
a explosé depuis le Covid.
25 % de téléchargements
en plus entre 2019 et 2021.
Exemple avec Vivoptim solutions.
Créée pour les clients de mutuelles,
l'application
propose un accompagnement
de santé en ligne
qui n'est pas uniquement digital.
Derrière l'écran
se cachent des professionnels
de santé bien réels,
physiquement présents
au siège de l'application.
-Allô ?
Je vous appelle
pour une consultation,
un bilan nutritionnel.
-Océane est diététicienne
pour Vivoptim solutions.
Aujourd'hui,
elle aide une patiente
qui souhaite perdre du poids.
-Je vais pas vous interdire
de manger ce petit carré
de chocolat, il y a pas de souci,
par contre, prenez le temps
de le déguster, pour éviter
d'avoir envie
d'en consommer un autre.
*-Oui, d'en reprendre un.
Je le mange très vite, ouais.
-Le but, c'est de pouvoir changer
les comportements,
d'améliorer leur santé
lorsqu'il y a une pathologie,
et quand il n'y en a pas,
c'est limiter l'apparition
d'une pathologie potentielle.
-Derrière cette vision,
il y a Virginie Femery,
directrice générale.
Pour elle,
les applications de e-santé
ont transformé
la prise en charge
des patients.
-Le numérique a vraiment permis
de révolutionner
les approches de prévention,
notamment en permettant d'avoir
quelque chose de plus personnalisé.
C'est notamment
par le biais de la donnée,
que les plateformes numériques
permettent de collecter,
qu'on peut ensuite
avoir ce meilleur ciblage,
cette meilleur personnalisation
des approches.
-Grâce à cette personnalisation,
certaines applications
permettent aussi de surveiller
la santé des patients
atteints de maladies chroniques,
comme Satelia, une application
de télésuivi.
Parmi ses utilisateurs,
il y a Nicole,
insuffisante cardiaque.
A 78 ans, elle se connecte
régulièrement.
Ainsi, tous les lundis,
c'est la même routine.
Musique légère
...
-Là, c'était 45,600,
ce matin, je crois.
Est-ce que je tousse ?
Pas du tout.
Je me sens pas
essoufflée.
Les chevilles ne sont pas gonflées.
Je me sens pas du tout fatiguée.
Je valide.
Terminé.
Voilà.
Ca me permet de voir
l'évolution de ma maladie
et de gérer un peu,
de voir où j'en suis.
C'est rassurant,
parce qu'on se sent...
pas tout seul.
-Mais pas de chance,
ce jour-là.
Nicole réalise
qu'elle vient de se tromper
dans un de ses réponses.
-J'ai mis 45,800 et c'est 46,800,
et 46,600.
-Vous pouvez pas revenir
en arrière ?
-Non.
J'essaie, mais ça marche pas.
"Contactez-nous", ils nous disent,
mais je sais pas qui contacter.
-Alors elle admet,
avec le numérique,
il lui manque quand même un peu
de contact humain.
-Dans les questions,
on demande de répondre presque
par oui ou par non.
Il y a pas de dialogue possible,
c'est ça.
-Pourtant, il existe bien,
car ses réponses sont envoyées
à l'hôpital de Bois-Gibert,
où elle est suivie.
Et ici, il y a un professionnel
chargé de surveiller
son état de santé, à distance.
Dès qu'un patient
communique des réponses
préoccupantes,
l'alerte est donnée au cardiologue.
-Par exemple,
pour ces patients, on voit bien
que la dernière semaine,
il a un score assez élevé,
et son poids
est vraiment déstabilisé.
Actuellement,
il a pris 6,5 kilos.
Effectivement, on prend contact
directement avec lui
pour lui expliquer,
lui poser des questions,
et lui proposer
des modifications thérapeutiques
de son traitement
en insuffisance cardiaque.
L'espace patient ne remplace pas
la consultation traditionnelle
et classique cardiologique.
Entre une consultation cardiologique
et la prochaine,
qui sont espacées
d'habitude de 3 mois à un an
chez un patient stable,
le patient est vraiment surveillé.
-Si avec le numérique,
le patient
devient acteur de sa santé,
il y a toujours une équipe médicale
derrière lui.
La Haute autorité de santé
souligne les bénéfices
de ces outils sur la qualité de vie
des patients.
La télésurveillance
sera bientôt prise en charge
par la Sécurité sociale.
-Professeur, évidemment,
c'est évident,
la valeur ajoutée,
pour le patient,
mais aussi, il y a cette accusation
de déshumanisation
qui a été formulée
dans le reportage.
Le risque existe ou pas ?
-Alors le risque,
il existe, évidemment.
Néanmoins, cet outil,
ce qui m'intéresse,
c'est qu'il va amener
un élément d'intermédiation
entre le patient
et son professionnel de santé,
et surtout, c'est bien dit
dans le reportage,
il va permettre de faire
ce qu'un professionnel
ne faisait pas, c'est-à-dire suivre
parfois de façon pluriquotidienne
un patient et pouvoir
détecter plus précocement
des éventuelles complications,
des alertes, etc.,
et d'aller chercher
le patient ou de l'appeler
quand on voit des anomalies,
ce qu'on avait
pas forcément auparavant,
avec des patients arrivant
aux urgences au dernier moment.
-Est-ce que c'est délirant
d'imaginer
que dans certains cabinets,
il y ait demain
des médecins robots ?
-Ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
et vous donne une petite idée
de vers là où on va,
c'est qu'il y a une partie
des consultations qui sont
des questions répétitives
d'informations standardisées
que le patient peut faire
sans le professionnel de santé.
-C'est ce qu'on a vu
dans le reportage.
-Absolument.
Donc une partie de la consultation
peut être numérisée et automatisée,
et le professionnel de santé,
quand il voit le patient,
va avoir ces informations
qui seront recueillies
et va pouvoir ensuite dédier
vraiment du temps
pour d'autres aspects,
notamment des aspects relationnels
ou des aspects
d'examens cliniques
et économiser du temps
dans la recherche
des informations.
Et demain, c'est l'outil qui ira
chercher lui-même de l'information.
Le patient n'aura plus besoin
de la rentrer.
-Comment il ira le chercher ?
-On a maintenant
des outils permettant
par exemple
de prendre les constantes vitales
avec une caméra.
-La température...
-La fréquence cardiaque,
la pression artérielle...
-Ca existe, ça, déjà ?
-Dans la recherche,
mais ça commence à être utilisé.
-Pour le suivi de maladies
chroniques, ce serait formidable.
-Tout à fait.
-Alors l'e-santé, vous y avez
fait allusion tout à l'heure,
c'est l'intelligence artificielle,
aussi en plein développement
dans tous les compartiments du jeu,
dans la santé, et pour la santé.
Alexia Léperon,
pour "Etat de santé",
est allée voir ce qui se fait
en imagerie cérébrale.
Reportage.
-On l'imaginait, il y a peu encore,
prête à remplacer les radiologues.
Mais aujourd'hui,
l'intelligence artificielle
a été reléguée
au rôle d'assistant du médecin.
Dans ce service d'imagerie,
l'intelligence artificielle
a fait son entrée en 2021
dans la prise en charge des AVC.
Lorsqu'un patient est touché,
l'IRM permet de voir
quelles zones du cerveau restent
encore sauvables. C'est là
que l'intelligence artificielle,
que l'on surnomme l'IA, intervient.
-Vous voyez, ici, en vert,
toute la zone
qui n'est pas encore infarcie,
qui est la zone sauvable,
que l'on appelle la zone
de pénombre.
Elle est en souffrance
mais elle n'est pas encore perdue
pour le cerveau du patient.
Ca veut dire que,
si rien n'est fait,
eh bien,
l'ensemble du cerveau,
la partie rouge,
qui est déjà perdue,
et la partie verte,
qui est encore sauvable,
si rien n'est fait d'un point de vue
thérapeutique,
toute cette portion, ici, verte,
sauvable,
va se transformer,
en 24 heures environ,
en partie rouge
non sauvable.
Ce que nous apporte l'IA,
c'est la capacité de répondre,
dans un temps très court,
à deux questions.
Premièrement :
y a-t-il une zone à sauver ?
Elle est visuelle,
il nous la montre ici,
sans qu'on ait besoin
de lancer
les post-traitements
de la perfusion.
Et deuxièmement :
est-on dans les critères
de recommandation
en termes de volume
pour le choix du traitement ?
-Pour autant,
si l'intelligence artificielle
est capable de réaliser certaines
tâches plus rapidement,
on ne peut pas compter
uniquement sur elle,
car elle peut se tromper.
Exemple avec un autre patient.
-Cette fois, on est toujours
face à une lésion
qui est visible
en séquence de diffusion,
qui pourrait s'appréhender
comme un accident vasculaire
cérébral ischémique,
et d'ailleurs,
l'IA va fonctionner dessus
comme si c'était un AVC
ischémique.
Or, dans le cas de cette patiente,
ce n'est pas un AVC ischémique.
Ca mime cliniquement,
et en imagerie,
un AVC ischémique,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
un "stroke mimics",
mais en fait,
c'est une autre pathologie,
Les IA n'ont jamais 100 % raison.
Ca n'existe pas.
On utilise vraiment l'IA
comme une aide au diagnostic,
mais une aide qui ne doit pas
remplacer l'expertise
ni la connaissance humaine
sur laquelle est basée la médecine
depuis des années.
-Pourquoi l'intelligence
artificielle peut-elle confondre
des pathologies que le médecin
humain reconnaît tout de suite ?
Les intelligences artificielles
sont basées sur une technologie
appelée "deep learning"
qui a connu un essor fulgurant
dans les années 2010.
A la manière du cerveau humain,
la machine va être capable
d'apprendre
par elle-même.
Pour cela,
l'algorithme est formé à analyser
des milliers d'images de patients.
A Paris, c'est sur ce type
d'algorithme
que travaille une équipe
de l'Institut du cerveau.
Menés par cette chercheuse,
ils tentent de développer
une intelligence artificielle
pour diagnostiquer
des maladies neurodégénératives
-Si on veut faire en sorte
qu'un algorithme puisse différencier
les images de sujets sains
d'images de patients,
on va pas arrêter de lui montrer
des images de sujets sains
en disant "ça, c'est un sujet sain",
des images de patients, en disant
"ça, c'est l'image de quelqu'un
qui a une pathologie",
et au fur et à mesure,
l'algorithme va être capable
de faire la différence
entre des images de sujets sains,
des images de patients,
et quand on lui présentera l'image
d'un sujet inconnu,
il sera capable de nous dire
si c'est l'image d'un sujet sain
ou d'un patient.
-Au coeur de cet apprentissage,
il y a donc
ces milliers d'images IRM
de sujets.
Ce sont les données,
la clé de voûte
de l'intelligence artificielle.
-Ce qui est vraiment important,
c'est d'avoir
suffisamment de données
et de données représentatives
du cadre...
d'application.
Si un algorithme
n'a été entraîné qu'avec...
Les images, par exemple,
d'hommes âgés de 60 ans
en bonne santé,
ils ne vont pas être capables
d'avoir de bonnes prédictions
sur les images de femmes de 30 ans
en mauvaise santé.
-Aujourd'hui, l'accès aux données
est donc le prérequis impératif
pour la conception d'IA
performantes et fiables.
Mais de nombreuses questions
éthiques et législatives
entourent l'accès
aux bases de données de santé,
ce qui peut rendre leur utilisation
par les chercheurs plus compliquée.
-Qu'est-ce que l'application
de l'imagerie artificielle
fait de plus
qu'une imagerie d'IRM ?
-De façon très simple,
je peux vous dire par exemple
que l'oeil humain est capable
de détecter 11 niveaux
de gris, puisque les images sont
en noir et blanc,
sur l'IRM, alors que la machine
peut en détecter plus de 1000.
Donc c'est une analyse
plus précise.
-Infiniment plus précise.
-Elle peut le faire
plus rapidement.
-C'est immédiat,
quasiment.
et c'est des centaines d'examens
qu'on peut analyser très rapidement.
-Et intervenir d'autant plus vite
pour sauver le malade.
-Exactement.
-Dans le cerveau
ou dans le coeur,
quand on manque d'oxygène, comme ça,
eh bien le temps est un facteur-clé
pour sauver les patients.
Dans le cancer,
on peut maintenant diagnostiquer
l'origine de cancers qui étaient
auparavant d'origine indéterminée,
qu'on pourra traiter avec
des pronostics qui vont changer.
-Il y a une question majeure,
quand on parle de numérique,
c'est le traitement des données.
Tout ça, vous l'avez dit,
c'est fondé sur une grande quantité
de données qu'on est capable
d'analyser avec des résultats
qui sont très positifs
pour le patient.
Mais ces données sont les nôtres.
Il y a des barrières,
en particulier en France.
Jusqu'où doit-on aller
dans l'analyse des données,
dans l'utilisation des données,
qui dépendent aussi du patient ?
-On a la capacité aujourd'hui
de générer de plus en plus
de données,
ce qui veut dire
de pouvoir ensuite
analyser de plus en plus
de paramètres de fonctionnement,
à la fois pour mieux comprendre
notre état de santé
mais aussi avec la potentialité
de réutiliser ces données
pour générer des progrès
comme l'intelligence artificielle
ou d'autres algorithmes.
Ce qui est très important,
aujourd'hui, de donner les règles
et le cadre de confiance
pour pouvoir utiliser
de façon sécurisée ces données,
garantir qu'elles vont être
destinées
à améliorer le fonctionnement
du système de santé,
à améliorer la détection
de certaines pathologies, etc.
Et le faire dans un cadre souverain.
-Pour l'intérêt général.
C'est la question
que vous avez souhaité poser
à un parlementaire, comme c'est
la règle dans l'émission.
Comment peut-on favoriser
l'utilisation
des données de santé ?
Philippe Latombe est député MoDem
de Vendée, il vous répond.
-Pour ça, il faut qu'on ait
un cadre clair,
de conservation des données de santé
et d'utilisation
des données de santé, à terme.
Ca nécessite de protéger ces données
de façon importante,
qu'il y ait des couches
de cybersécurité suffisantes
pour que nos concitoyens
aient confiance et puissent penser
qu'elles sont bien gardées
et utilisées à bon escient.
Ensuite, il faudra expliquer
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a besoin
de ces données,
et que c'est pas simplement
pour la personne, tout de suite,
mais ça peut être aussi
pour des recherches de long terme.
-Voilà pour la réponse politique
à ce stade.
Vous êtes, vous,
favorable à quoi ?
-Il y a plusieurs éléments
importants.
Le 1er, sur ce sujet-là,
c'est la confiance,
qu'on puisse expliquer
ce qu'on fait.
Le 2e, c'est qu'on a besoin
de ces données
pour faire progresser
notre système de santé.
Tous les pays dans le monde
ont commencé
à exploiter ces données.
C'est le cas aussi en France
mais il faut qu'on aille à une
vitesse supérieure.
-On est en retard ?
-On n'est pas en regard
car on a une expertise médicale
qui est très forte,
qui est basée sur notre héritage,
simplement,
on voit qu'on a besoin
d'accéder plus rapidement
à ces données
et développer des grands entrepôts
de données de façon sécurisée.
3e élément qui revient,
aux questions de confiance,
également, c'est informer
et éduquer sur la donnée.
-C'est d'ailleurs ce que dit
le député, de la même façon.
-C'est un élément complexe
mais il faut que tout le monde
comprenne que,
quand on utilise un smartphone
ou des réseaux sociaux,
on va,
sans forcément le savoir,
ni avoir donné son consentement,
envoyer beaucoup de données
à des entreprises étrangères
qui vont les utiliser
et qui, parfois, vous connaissent
mieux que vous-mêmes.
-Merci beaucoup,
professeur Tesnière.
On sait que vous vous y employez,
en tout cas,
à faire en sorte
que tout soit accompagné,
avec l'argent nécessaire,
si besoin.
Merci beaucoup.
-Merci.
-Et à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro d'"Etat de santé".
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique